zumindest
tierhaltungskennzeichenspflicht Jim
Özdemir der Bundesminister für Ernährung
Landwirtschaft ist der erste Redner es
geht jetzt weiter hier bei Phoenix mit
der
tierhaltungskennzeichnungspflicht und
dieses und noch viel mehr jetzt auch mit
einer neuen Kommentatorin am Phönix
Mikrofon mit Katharina kühn
notwendige Veränderungen und Anpassungen
fallen aber dann leichter wenn die
wirtschaftliche Lage gut ist und deshalb
freut es mich dass die aktuellen
Wirtschaftszahlen in der Landwirtschaft
nach Jahren des Rückgangs und der
Stagnation aktuell positiv sind zugleich
zugleich wissen wir aber auch dass
gerade in der Schweinehaltung die
Situation weiter sehr schwierig und
dramatisch ist der Veränderungsdruck ist
immens aber die Veränderungsbereitschaft
unserer Landwirte und Landwirte ist es
auch unsere Aufgabe ist es diese
Veränderungsbereitschaft zu unterstützen
die Lösungen dafür liegen seit vielen
Jahren auf dem Tisch es wurde viel
geredet vieles auch zerredet die
Unionsfraktion wird sich vielleicht
trotz mancher Probleme mit dem
Langzeitgedächtnis daran erinnern wir
müssen jetzt endlich loslegen
Verbraucherinnen und Verbraucher wollen
zu recht wissen was da in ihrem
Einkaufskorb liegt sie wollen wissen wie
das Tier gelebt hat dessen Fleisch auf
ihre Teller kommt und zwar nicht doch
freiwilliger sondern verbindlicher Basis
und damit auch verlässlich und damit
umfassend dieser
dieser Gesetzentwurf ist ein erster
Schritt um dieses Ziel zu erreichen es
werden weitere Schritte und zwar in
dieser Legislaturperiode Folgen dazu
gehört die Ausweitung auf Sauen und
Ferkel sowie weitere Tierarten dazu
gehört die Ausweitung auf weitere
Bereiche der Wertschöpfung wie
Gastronomie und verarbeitete Produkte
aber ich bitte Sie auch seien wir an
dieser Stelle ehrlich miteinander wenn
wir alles auf einmal machen wollten dann
würde nichts passieren das ist schon mal
versucht worden und wie es ausging
wissen wir alles ist gescheitert
aber
dass sie jetzt von der Opposition auch
allen Ernstes fordern eine
verpflichtende nationale Kennzeichnung
auch für importierte Ware einzuführen
obwohl sie genau wissen dass es
europawächsrechtswidrig wäre das finde
ich auch gegenüber den landwirtenden
Landwirten unehrlich sie wissen ganz
genau wen hier in cdu/csu
Landwirtschaftsminister oder Ministerin
stehen würde auch die können nicht gegen
Europa recht Vorgehen bitte sagen sind
Bauern nicht Dinge von denen Sie wissen
dass sie nicht wahr sind
aber spätestens seit an die scheuer und
seiner gescheiterten Maut wissen wir in
Sachen Europarecht sollte man sich
vielleicht besser nicht auf die
Expertise der Union verlassen
völlig klar dass die
Veränderungsbereitschaft unsere
Tierhalter nicht zu Nachteilen durch
importierte Produkte führen darf es geht
mir deshalb nicht allein um die
Transparenz bei der Haltung sondern auch
um die Transparenz bei der Herkunft
deshalb habe ich von Beginn an und ich
habe das hier ja oft genug gesagt in
Brüssel darauf gedrängt dass es
Verbesserung bei der
Herkunftskennzeichnung endlich kommen
muss wir haben jetzt die Zusage dass es
Anfang nächsten Jahres in Vorschlag
geben wird ich sage ja auch noch mal on
the record falsch Brüssel wieder
Erwarten nicht worthält ist mein Haus
drauf vorbereitet bei der Kennzeichnung
von Frischfleisch erweitern wir jetzt
schon die bestehende
Herkunftskennzeichnung auf unverpackte
Produkte
Verbraucherinnen und Verbraucher
erwarten nicht nur Klarheit bei der
Haltungsform sondern auch bei der
Herkunft auch dafür werden wir sorgen
das gilt auch für die notwendigen
Veränderungen im Baurecht der Umbau der
Stelle für mehr Tierwohl darf nicht
länger am Bauern genehmigungsrecht
scheitern wir müssen
wir müssen endlich die traurige Realität
beenden das Tiere an die Stelle
angepasst werden umgekehrt muss es
künftig sein die Stelle müssen sie an
die Tiere anpassen
die notwendigen Änderungen im Baurecht
werden noch vor der geplanten großen
Baugesetz Novelle umgesetzt ich danke an
dieser Stelle ausdrücklich meiner
Ministerkollegin Geiwitz dass sie das
jetzt anpackt wir wollen die Betriebe
beim Umbau auf finanziell unterstützen
nie hat eine Bundesregierung mehr in die
zukunftsfest die Tierhaltung investiert
an dieser Stelle auch mein
ausdrücklicher Dank an Finanzminister
Christian Lindner im Bundeshaushalt
haben wir in der Koalition die
Grundlagen für ein Bundesprogramm
geschaffen um Investitionen in den
stallumbau für mehr Tierwohl zu fördern
darüber hinaus und das ist ganz
entscheidend sollen laufende mehr Kosten
für mehr Tierwohl mit Verträgen bis zu
zehn Jahren unterstützt werden das ist
notwendig für die finanzielle
Planungssicherheit unsere Landwirtinnen
und Landwirte wir sorgen dafür dass die
Landwirte profitieren wenn sie auf mehr
Tierwohl setzen
ich bin guter Dinge und wir wissen in
der Koalition auch um die Erwartungen
die es draußen gibt bei den
landwirtenden Landwirten nach so vielen
Enttäuschungen dass die
koalitionsfraktion in den kommenden
Wochen einen guten Weg finden werden die
Finanzierung des Umbaus langfristig zu
gestalten und zu sichern denn jeder Euro
den wir in den Umbau der Tierhaltung
investieren ist wahrlich gut angelegtes
Geld wenn wir Stirn den Klimaschutz in
mehr Tierwohl wenn weniger Tiere besser
gehalten werden wir sichern damit die
Arbeit zu Lebensgrundlagen für junge für
die junge Generation unserer
Landwirtinnen und Landwirte damit
stärken wir auch ländliche Region alte
schaffen wir mit einer vertretbaren
Investition also sehr gut angelegtes
Geld
auch wenn wir
aber wenn wir jetzt investieren dann
werden die tierhaltenden Betriebe wenn
wir nicht investieren in Deutschland
dicht machen weil sie den ruinösen
Preiswettbewerb nicht bestehen können
deshalb müssen wir jetzt dafür sorgen
dass die dringend notwendigen
Investitionen auf den Höfen ankommen um
die Tierhaltung in Deutschland
zukunftsfest zu machen ja
der Umbau der Tierhaltung ist ein
Marathon wir haben aber nicht wie
vorherige Regierungen mutlos und zaghaft
darauf gewartet dass endlich in
stadtschuss passiert wir sind jetzt
einfach gestartet und genauso wenn ich
das an der Stelle sagen darf wie
übrigens Renate Künast vor jetzt 20
Jahren mit der Eierkennzeichnung damals
ein wichtiges Projekt auf den Weg
gebracht hat ist es jetzt Zeit für den
nächsten großen Schritt die
tierhaltungskennzeichnung und auf diesem
Weg ich nehme an dem Namen des ganzen
Hauses herzlichen Glückwunsch zum
Geburtstag liebe Renate
der Umbau
der Umbau beginnt ich freue mich über
jede Verbesserung des Gesetzentwurfs für
eine verbindlichstaatliche
tierhaltungskennzeichnung es gibt Kritik
aber ein Großteil der Kritik ist
eigentlich gar keine sondern beschreibt
vielmehr das was unsere nächsten
Schritte sein werden würden wir alles
auf einmal machen würden wir so enden
wie es bislang geendet ist nämlich beim
Stillstand den aber darf es angesichts
der dramatischen Lage nicht geben sonst
gibt es eben künftig nur noch Fleisch
aus dem Ausland und dort werden die
Tiere sicherlich nicht besser gehalten
wir können gemeinsam den Grundstein für
den Wandel legen lassen Sie uns
gemeinsam die Vorschläge der
borchert-kommission unter
Zukunftskommission Landwirtschaft
Schritt für Schritt umsetzen machen sie
mit liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen von
der Opposition um gemeinsam Klima Tieren
VerbraucherInnen Verbrauchern und
unseren tierhaltenden Betrieben gerecht
zu werden die Zeit herzlichen Dank
jim hat zu mir der Bundesminister für
Ernährung und Landwirtschaft hat hier
die Debatte zum
tierhaltungskennzeichnung
eröffnet dass hier die Einführung eines
Labels nun wirklich im nächsten Jahr
stattfinden soll und hier gibt es noch
mal ein paar Glückwünsche für Renate
Künast 67 Jahre wird sie heute alt und
ist ja eine der
profiliertesten Politikerin der Grünen
was auch den Verbraucherschutz angeht
und wie ist der Minister gesagt hat hat
sich auch schon mit dieser Thematik
häufiger auseinandergesetzt Albert
Stegemann und für die unionsfunktion
liebe Damen und Herren liebe Kolleginnen
Renate Künast auch von uns aus natürlich
herzlichen Glückwunsch zum Geburtstag
gar keine Frage ja heute in der vor
allen Dingen in dieser Debatte schaut
wirklich die komplette agrar und
Ernährungswirtschaft nach Berlin das
sind nicht nur
17.900 Schweinehalter nein das sind
insgesamt
4,4 Millionen Beschäftigte in agrar- und
Ernährungswirtschaft mit einem
Gesamtumsatz von 186 Milliarden Euro und
rund ein Viertel etwa 46 Milliarden Euro
erwirtschaftet alleine die
Fleischwirtschaft
wesentlicher Bestandteil der ländlichen
Räume der Wirtschaft macht am Ende auch
die Agrarpolitik aus und wie auch hier
die Grundlagen geschaffen werden und sie
sind als Landwirtschaftsminister wo der
ist gerade noch zur Abstimmung aber er
kommt schon wieder rein her als sie mir
Herr Minister sie sind als
Landwirtschaftsminister eben auch
Minister der ländlichen Räume und dafür
haben sie eine sehr große Verantwortung
leider treten sie als solcher überhaupt
nicht in Erscheinung und ich werde auch
gleich begründen warum ich das so
einschätze
wenn man sich mit dem
tierhaltungskennzeichen auseinandersetzt
muss man verstehen dass es zwei
wesentliche Ziele erfüllen muss damit es
überhaupt funktioniert einmal wieder
Name sagt tatsächlich da geht es um die
Kennzeichnung aber auch hier stellen wir
fest das ist ja gerade schon selbst vom
Minister angesprochen worden ist
wirklich wie ein Schweizer Käse es geht
tatsächlich nur für Schweinefleisch nur
für frisches Schweinefleisch also etwa
nur 25 bis 30 Prozent des Marktes es
wird kein Import berücksichtigt keine
kantinenware kein Gastro keine anderen
Tierarten keine Sauen keine Prozesse wir
haben hier in der letzten Legislatur
haben wir durchgesetzt dass wir keine
betäubungslose Ferkel Kastration haben
wollen die können jetzt aber importiert
werden das kann nicht wahr sein also das
ist sehr lückenhaft und von dieser
Stelle aus kann ich Ihnen hier nur eine
Schulnote 5 geben für das was das
haltungskennzeichen im wahrsten Sinne
des Wortes ausmacht
jetzt gibt es aber
und das ist das viel gewichtigere Thema
wir müssen beim Umbau der Tierhaltung
brauchen wir ein Gesamtkonzept und ich
glaube das ist eben kein Gesamtkonzept
gibt wir haben in der letzten Legislatur
gut
vorgearbeitet die burchard-kommission
die sie auch schon angesprochen haben
hat hervorragende Vorschläge gemacht und
im Grunde genommen ist es so dass eine
haltungskennzeichen in die höhere
Tierwohl Stufe führen muss sie stellen
jetzt öffentlich und Medien wirksam
diese Treppe ins politische Schaufenster
diese Treppe in die nächste Ebene von
mehr Tierwohl aber die zweite Etage
nämlich die borcher Kommission und deren
Umsetzung die hat die FDP bereits
weggesprengt und jetzt komme ich auch zu
den konkreten Zahlen sie haben
angesprochen sie wollen hier gerne sie
wollen gerne umsetzen 150 Millionen Euro
haben sie zur Verfügung gestellt lesen
Sie sich doch mal durch was heute in der
neuen osnabrücke Osnabrücker Zeitung
steht Miriam staute ihre Kollegin aus
Niedersachsen von den Grünen hat noch
mal beziffert dass der jährliche Bedarf
für einen Umbau der Tierhaltung bei vier
bis sieben Milliarden Euro liegt also da
hat ihre Kollegin im ausnahmsweise recht
orientieren sie sich daran mit ihren 150
Millionen kommen wir wirklich noch nicht
mal von 12 bis Mittag das reicht bei
weitem nicht und deswegen das ist das
entscheidende deswegen ist ihr
Gesetzesentwurf wirklich überhaupt
komplett untauglich weil das
grundsätzliche Ziel die Tierhaltung in
Deutschland in irgendeiner Form
weiterzuentwickeln komplett verfehlt sie
haben eine Patrone im Lauf gehabt diese
Chance haben sie vertan sie schießen in
die Luft effekttasche rein dabei kommt
nichts rum und das kann ich Ihnen
wirklich leider nur sehr übernehmen und
und die wirklich herzlich bitten hier
auch nochmal
nachzuarbeiten so jetzt könnte man ja
könnte man sich einfach machen wir sind
jetzt am Ende des Jahres und sie sagen
als Minister würden Sie gerne auch noch
mal einen grünen Haken an das eine oder
andere Gesetzespaket machen sagen wir
dann ist es auch wenn es nicht viel geht
aber dann ist es unschädlich aber auch
damit müssen wir mal aufräumen es ist
nicht unschädlich es gibt nämlich
funktionierende Initiativen
privatwirtschaftliche Initiativen wie
die Initiative Tierwohl die
funktionieren einwandfrei dort werden
jedes Jahr 150 Millionen Euro gemeinsam
mit dem Lebensmittel Einzelhandel
gemeinsam mit der Branche
tierwohlgerecht investiert die Landwirte
machen es es funktioniert es sind 90%
der
Geflügels in Deutschland ist
angeschlossen bei der Initiative
Tierwohl 68% der Schweinefleisches wird
auch durch die Initiative Tierwohl
gefördert und den Tieren geht es besser
geht es besser als in den meisten
anderen europäischen Stellen dieses gute
funktionierende System machen sie durch
ihre durch ihre Zone bzw durch das
Verbot dass das ITW ihr Leben künftig
neben ihrem abdrucken darf machen sie
die ITW kaputt sie zerstören ein
funktionierendes gutes System was auch
in der Praxis bereits umgesetzt wurde
und das was sie nachschieben
funktioniert eben nicht und deswegen
machen sie etwas kaputt ich kann Ihnen
nur sagen überdenken Sie was Sie hier
machen das ist kein konstruktiver
Beitrag zu mehr Tierwohl es ist wirklich
ein sehr sehr schlechter Gesetzentwurf
und wir werden nicht aufhören ihn zu
empfehlen bringt noch mal darüber
nachzudenken und ihre Aufgabe als
bundeslandwirtschaftsminister endlich
wahrzunehmen vielen Dank
der Sprecher für Ernährung und
Landwirtschaft der Unionsfraktion Albert
Stegemann hier sehr unzufrieden mit dem
vorliegenden
Gesetzentwurf der Bundesregierung dass
ein Tierschutzlabel eingeführt wird das
ja auch schon die Vorgängerin
Julia Klöckner beschäftigt hat wir sehen
jetzt hier noch mal einige Abgeordnete
in die Island denn es läuft ja noch die
Abstimmung zur Strompreis Bremse und wer
jetzt noch nicht abgestimmt hat jetzt
nur noch ein paar Minuten dafür Zeit
die SPD wir bleiben aber erst für
thematisch natürlich bei dieser Debatte
und da ist die nächste Rednerin Susanne
Mittag die Sprecherin für Ernährung und
Landwirtschaft der Sozialdemokraten hier
im Deutschen Bundestag ja das ist sehr
nett
recht beeil mich auch sehr geehrte Frau
Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen Kollegen
das muss jetzt aber mal sein das ist
jetzt ein guter Tag für die Tierhaltung
der erste praktische Schritt für den
Umbau in der Nutztierhaltung da wird
einiges deutlich werden auch für ein
Stegemann die Transformation in die
Zukunft die Notwendigkeit wird ja wohl
seit Jahren bis heute gesehen debattiert
von Verbänden von Landwirten Vermarktung
und Politik und der Druck wird immer
größer und nein es funktioniert derzeit
nicht gut deswegen ist es ja so wichtig
verhandelt und konzeptionell erarbeitet
von Betroffenen und Fachleuten nicht von
der Politik und uns mit der Bitte
übergeben einen rechtssicheren Rahmen zu
schaffen genauso ist es mal eingeteilt
worden und das hätten wir auch gerne in
der letzten Legislatur umgesetzt aber
ein unvollständiger Entwurf vom
Ministerium und nur freiwillig partiell
das war von vornherein zum Scheitern
verurteilt und konnte nicht
funktionieren
das sieht jetzt anders aus die
Tierhaltung wird sich verbessern die
Kennzeichnung ist verpflichtend es geht
nämlich die Standard sind
nachvollziehbar und überprüfbar und
nicht nur von marktinfressen geleitet
sondern auf Tierwohl ausgerichtet und
verlässlich für die Landwirten und
Landwirte es ist ein guter Tag es ist
das erste Gesetz von insgesamt 9
Gesetzen und Verordnung vielleicht mal
zu Klärung was vermutlich für einige ein
wenig überraschend ist besonders für die
CDU das ist aber notwendig und das ganze
Thema zu fassen von Geburt bis
Schlachtung für alle drei Nutztierarten
für Verarbeitung verkauft privat
Gastronomie Kantine das war vorher auch
nicht und für die gesamten tierischen
Erzeugnisse ergänzen dazu während der
Zeit die baurechtsanpassung verhandelt
der Bereich Emission und Finanzierung
dazu gibt es noch Anpassung im
Tierschutzgesetz auch bei der
tiergesundheitsdatenbank all das gehört
zu einem tragfähigen Konzept und ebenso
wie eine herkunftskenn Bezeichnung ist
aber ja schon gesagt worden entweder die
EU macht eine Vorlage oder wir machen es
selbst jeder Landwirt jede Landwirtin
kann frei entscheiden ob er oder sie
teilnimmt aber das Label das Leben in
der haltungsbedingung das ist
verpflichtend das wird gerne mal in
öffentlichen Debatten alles in ein Top
geworfen was für Gründe auch immer
trennen aber wir sind auch überzeugt
dass jede Landwirtin und jeder Landwirt
sehr wohl selbst entscheiden kann soll
und will wie die Tierhaltung der Zukunft
für einen eigenen Betrieb aussieht und
es ist nun absehbar das bei allen
tierischen Erzeugnissen dies erkennbar
ist und auch sehr einfach erkennbar ist
alle Vergleiche mit bisher vorhandenen
Leben hinken denn diese sind
privatwirtschaftlich orientiert umfassen
nur Teilbereiche sind oft nicht
nachvollziehbar und unzuverlässig sei es
für Landwirten und für Landwirte die
heutzutage oft mit immer neuen
kurzfristigen Anforderungen an ihre
Erzeugnisse unterliegen ihre Erzeuger
Kosten vom Handelspartner oftmals nicht
oder nur teilweise bezahlt bekommen und
verbrauchen und Verbraucher die bei der
lebensflut mit Bildern und verwirrenden
Begriffen oft einen haltungsstandard
vorgegaukelt bekommen der eine
Überprüfung nicht mal ansatzweise
standhalten würde
jedoch bei aller Begeisterung bei aller
Begeisterung dass es endlich vorangeht
gibt es natürlich auch
Nachbesserungsbedarf das nach einer
ersten Lesung immer so und den haben wir
auch schon deutlich angemeldet da gibt
es eine ganze Bandbreite sei es bei den
Details bei den Haltungsbedingungen beim
Fehlen im Bereich Aufzucht und Ferkel in
dem Gesetz um nur einige zu nennen
unseren Koalitionspartnern geht es
ähnlich aber die Verhandlungen laufen
schon und sind sehr konstruktiv nicht
nur so ziemlich alle Verbände haben
aufgelistet was fehlt und verbessert
werden muss auch die Länder haben nach
der ersten Lesung im Bundesrat eine sehr
lange Liste von Anmerkungen und
Forderungen erstellt die gesamt
insgesamt sehr fundierten
Verbesserungsvorschläge umfassen
allerdings nicht nur die vorliegende
Gesetzesvorlage sondern gesamte Konzept
das in diesem Gesetz ja noch gar nicht
komplett erfasst ist ich erinnere neun
Gesetze und Verordnung Baurecht Emission
Finanzierungskonzept mit der
Festschreibung der Fördermöglichkeiten
beim Umbau sowie der finanziellen
Absicherung des Mehraufwandes bei den
Erlösen bessere Haltung kostet nun mal
mehr das darf nicht nur als Werbung
vermarkten die bislang sondern der
Mehraufwand muss auch bei den Landwirten
und Landwirten endlich mal ankommen und
nicht als Marketing erlöst bei den
Verarbeitern oder Verkäufern bleiben so
wie es oftmals jetzt ist nein es ist
nicht
diese Systematik ist teilweise eine
Abkehr der vorherigen Vorgehensweise
ungewöhnlich kann aber auch von Vorteil
sein wie zum Beispiel in dem
Zusammenhang die geplante Verordnung für
Transport und Schlachtung die für alle
Kategorien gelten soll vereinfacht aber
trotzdem verbessert und dieser erste
Teilabschnitt dient auch dem Euro der
europäischen Notifizierung die schon auf
dem Weg und zwar auf einem guten Weg ist
wichtig ist daher die Umsetzung eines
Gesamtpaketes dass alle Maßnahmen
ineinander greifen und zwar zeitnah zu
verwirklichen sind und zeitnah ist
wirklich ganz ernst gemeint genau kommt
an das heißt Gesetze und Vorordnung
beschließen Finanzierung sichern und
damit Verlässlichkeit dokumentieren
Landwirte die finanzieren müssen und
bauen wollen für Kommunen die genehmigen
wollen und müssen für Verarbeiter
Zulieferer verkauft Gastronomie und
kantin die kennzeichnen müssen und für
viele andere Bereiche auf die Umstellung
und Anpassungen noch zukommen
dass die Rahmenbedingungen im nächsten
jahrzehnbar sind um sich darauf
vorzubereiten und einzustellen es
besteht eine sehr große
Erwartungshaltung viel Skepsis nach so
vielen Enttäuschungen und eine enorme
Bereitschaft sich auf die Zukunft
einzulassen das hier ist der erste
Schritt und ich freue mich auf die
weiteren danke schön
sagt Susanne Mittag sie hat hier auch
auf die Änderungsvorschläge der
Bundesländer hingewiesen die zwar dem
Entwurf Anfang Dezember zugestimmt haben
aber halt eben nur mit knapp 60
Änderungsvorschlägen unter anderem wird
eben kritisiert dass momentan sich
dieser
Gesetzentwurf nur auf die Mast
beschränkt und eben andere
Aspekte der fleisch-erzeugung noch nicht
berücksichtigt werden Ferkel Erzeugung
Aufzucht Transport oder auch
geschlachtung aber auch dass er dir so
seine Mutter gesagt das ist nun mal so
dass nach einer ersten Lesung ist noch
etliche Änderung gibt und Susanne Mittag
hat jetzt auch abgestimmt für die
strompreisbremsen das konnte sie nicht
weil sie ja beim Reden war das heißt die
Zahl Dienerin und Saal Diener werden nun
hier die Stimmen auszählen das Ergebnis
hören wir dann später jetzt hören
erstmal Stefan proczka zu für die
afd-fraktion der agrarpolitische
Sprecher sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin
Herr Minister meine Damen und Herren
Gott zum Kruse mit dem vorliegenden
Gesetzentwurf möchte Münster Özdemir die
Haltungsform bei frischen
Schweinefleisch einheitlich kennzeichnen
so weit so gut könnte man jetzt sagen
wenn ich sie zur solche Kennzeichnung
nicht schon längst gäbe was sie aber
gegen Vorhaben Herr Minister Genre den
Beteiligten in erster Linie schauen sie
mit ihrer Kennzeichnung in deutschen
schweinehalten denn für die Betriebe
bedeutet der neue Bürokratieaufwand
erhebliche Mehrkosten weil ausländische
Marktteilnehmer diese mehr Kosten nicht
haben schaffen sie gleichzeitig einen
massiven
Wettbewerbsnachteil für die heimische
Landwirtschaft und das würden wir nicht
durchgelassen da stellen wir uns dagegen
zweitens hat die tierhaltungskennzeichen
keinerlei Einfluss auf bessere
Haltungsbedingungen oder den Tierschutz
denn warum sollte ein Schweinehalter
seinen Stall für mehrere Millionen Euro
umbauen und die Haltungsbedingungen
verbessern wenn er dann auf den Kosten
sitzen bleibt weil niemand die teure
Ware kauft falls Sie Herr Minister in
ihren Elfenbeinturm noch nicht
mitbekommen haben sollten befinden wir
uns inmitten einer der schwersten
Inflationen seit den 50er Jahren die
meisten Deutschen können sich schon
heute kaum noch Fleisch leisten gut
vielleicht ist es Absicht der Grünen das
weiß ich nicht aber das ist halt eine
Katastrophe momentan 3
drittens gibt es auch keinerlei Mehrwert
für den Verbraucher denn die
Kennzeichnung gibt nämlich anders als
behauptet keine Auskunft darüber ob die
Haltung besonders artgerecht ist
Aufzucht und Transport zum Beispiel
werden gar nicht berücksichtigt in ihrem
Gesetz hier sind die bereits am Markt
existierenden privatwirtschaftlichen
iTV schon angesprochen worden
tierschutzkennzeichen deutlich weiter
als ihre Pläne und ihre Pläne sind
vermutlich nur zur Täuschung des
Verbrauchers doch meine Damen und Herren
kurz zusammen
ihre staatliche
tierhaltungskennzeichnung diskriminiert
die heimischen Schweinehalter und
verteuert die Produktion massiv das
bedeutet auch dass es heimische Fleisch
künstlich teurer gemacht hat teure
gemacht wird und das inmitten der
aktuellen Krise die man aktuell am
gleichzeitig verbessern sie nicht die
Haltungsbedingungen sondern Schaden
sogar dem Tierschutz in der Schule würde
man sagen setzen 6 kein Wunder dass so
gut wie die
so gut wie alle relevanten
Herzinfarkt ganz ruhig ganz chillig
bleiben ganz ruhig bleiben
wird besser kein Wunder dass sie so
das so gut wie alle relevanten Verbände
egal ob Landwirtschaft oder des
handelsun sogar Tier- und
Umweltschutzverbände Sturm gegen ihre
praxisfremden Plänen laufen sogar der
Bundesrat haben wir schon gehört hat 60
Änderungen an Ihren Entwurf eingefordert
das machen sie ihr Minister ignorieren
diese Kritik einfach und wollen ihre
Kennzeichnungspflicht trotz allem und
gegen jede Not durch den Deutschen
Bundestag Boxen sie und dass sie
unbelehrbar sind das muss man ja bereits
ob er die unerträgliche Ignoranz
gegenüber allen Einwänden der
beteiligten Akteure zeig mir welches
Geistes Kind sie Wirklichkeit sind und
wie sehr sie unsere freiheitliche
marktwirtschaftliche Demokratie
verachten mit uns ist sie sinnlich zu
machen meine Damen und Herren der
einzige richtige Weg wäre eine
vernünftige herkunftskennzahl sein das
hilft allen Tierhaltern und den
verbrauchen denn entsprechende Antwort
liegt dir vor der ist angehängt an
diesen Sachen und wie es richtig
funktioniert werden zweiten Redebeitrag
mein Kollege Peter Völser erklären den
Landwirtschaft Umweltschutz und
Tierschutz funktioniert nur mit der AFD
Dankeschön meine Damen und Herren
stefan proczka war das für die
afd-fraktion er hat es gesagt die
afd-fraktion hat hier auch einen Antrag
eingereicht mit dem Titel eine
transparente
herkunftszeitung als Voraussetzung für
eine freie und mündige Kauf Entscheidung
dieser Antrag wird hier zum ersten Mal
beraten Karina Konrad spricht nun für
die FDP-Fraktion sie ist
stellvertretende Fraktionsvorsitzender
vielen Dank sehr geehrte Frau
Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen wir beraten heute in der ersten
Lesung im Gesetzentwurf zur Einführung
einer staatlichen
tierhaltungskennzeichnung wir Freie
Demokraten wollen eine verpflichtende
staatliche tierhaltungskennzeichnung
europaweit schon seit sehr sehr langer
Zeit von daher bin ich sehr froh dass
wir das hier heute machen was wollen wir
mit dieser
Kennzeichnung erreichen wir wollen mehr
Landwirten eine verlässliche Basis
schaffen dafür dass sie tatsächlich auch
von mehr Tierwohl in ihren Stellen
profitieren können indem durch eine
staatliche Kennzeichnung endlich die
notwendige und verlässliche Transparenz
für die Verbraucher an der Ladentheke
hergestellt wird und dieses Gesetz was
wir hier heute haben das ist für uns
eine Arbeitsgrundlage nahezu alle
Verbände Stakeholder rund um die
Landwirtschaft vom Tierschutz bis zum
Bauernverband der Handel haben uns in
ihren Stellungnahmen auch schon
wertvolle Ratschläge gegeben und nicht
bin froh dass diese wertvollen
Ratschläge eingegangen sind nicht
wundere mich ehrlicherweise über die
Opposition an der Stelle die nur
kritisiert aber keinen einzigen Beitrag
geleistet hat bisher dazu in der Debatte
mal zu sagen was denn besser gehen kann
worum geht es denn uns ein Demokraten an
der Stelle das will ich kurz
verdeutlichen erstens ist doch ganz klar
Landwirte die bereits den Weg
beschritten haben und in mehr Tierwohl
investiert haben die dürfen doch am Ende
nicht die dummen sein deshalb haben wir
uns innerhalb der Ampel auch schon
darauf verständigt dass sich das Label
an bestehenden Initiativen auch am
orientieren muss wir wollen zweitens das
Tierwohl auf keinen Fall nur auf dem
Papier im Gesetzestext verankern sondern
wir wollen auch dass es in der Praxis
stattfinden kann deshalb müssen wir auch
ermöglichen dass Tierwohl umgesetzt
werden kann und er ötzte mehr hat es ja
verdeutlicht dafür sind Änderungen im
Baurecht nötig und sind auch Änderungen
im Umwelt
emissionsschutzgesetz ganz konkret bei
der TA-Luft notwendig und das müssen wir
auch machen und ich hätte es auch gut
gefunden wenn wir direkt die erste
Lesung der Baurechte Debatte heute mit
hätten anschließen können das wird
folgen und bei der TA Luft da müssen
auch Kölner ihren Beitrag leisten und da
können sie dann auch mal vielleicht
konkrete Vorschläge machen wie man denn
tatsächlich
baurechtliche weichen hier auch so
stellt das Landwirte dazu befähigt
werden Tierwohl auch umzusetzen denn die
Zeit dieser verantwortungsschieberei die
muss ja jetzt definitiv mal vorbei sein
wer auf den Höfen unterwegs ist der
merkt doch was los ist und so kann es
auf jeden Fall nicht weitergehen denn
wir wollen Landwirten eine verlässliche
Basis und Planungssicherheit schaffen
und diese Kennzeichnung die ist für uns
auch kein Ziel oder kein Ventil für die
einzelbetriebliche Reduktion von
Tierbeständen ich will mal ein Beispiel
sagen worum geht es uns mich hat ein
junger Mann angerufen der ist 22 Jahre
alten er will den Hof von seinem Vater
übernehmen
Schweinestall mit 500 Mastplätzen
umbauen zu mehr Tierwohl und das kann er
im Moment nicht weil ihn da
baurechtliche Hürden daran hindern und
diesem jungen Mann der ja hohe
sechsstellige Beträge bereit ist in die
Hand zu nehmen um tatsächlich auch in
Tierwohl zu investieren die müssen wir
doch den Weg ebnen dass das auch möglich
ist dass er diesen Markt den er sich
bereits erschlossen hat bedienen kann
und dass er tatsächlich auch noch im
Laufe seiner Lebenszeit der ist ja noch
sehr jung auch eine Entwicklung machen
kann das ist doch das was die
Gesellschaft erwartet was möglich sein
müssen das werden wir doch wohl
hinkriegen dass hier zu machen und
lassen sie mich zum Abschluss noch ein
Wort auch sagen weil das Thema der
Finanzierung natürlich auch alle
umtreibt unser wir kennen das doch und
das ist eine gesamtgesellschaftliche
Aufgabe dafür zu sorgen dass mehr
Tierschutz notwendig ist und da müssen
auch alle Akteure in der
Wertschöpfungskette ihren Beitrag dazu
leisten und der Handel überbietet sich
dabei um das ärgert mich wirklich
bessere Haltungsformen in seinen
werbeplättchen für sich zu bewerben und
zumindest jetzt muss doch mal der
Zeitpunkt sein dass auch den Worten
Taten folgen muss wenn Sie sich zum
Schluss nicht zum Nulltarif wir müssen
den Weg Ebenen als Staat das begleiten
wir auch aber jeder muss auch seinen
Beitrag leisten denn wir können
dauerhaft die Schäden
quersubventionieren diese Preispolitik
wie sie da ist passiert und da werden
wir auch eine gute Lösung finden um die
Gespräche auch nicht Scheunen an der
Stelle vielen Dank
und für die Linke hat das Wort Inhalator
[Applaus]
[Musik]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kollegen und Kollegen grundsätzlich
begrüßen wir linken die verbindliche
tierhaltungskennzeichnung auf
Lebensmittel die freiwillige
Kennzeichnung wie ist der Handel gerade
macht umfasst eben nicht alle
fleischangebote und es haben nicht alle
Hersteller mitgebracht ziel dieses
Lebens war vor allem
sich als vermarktungskriterium von
Konkurrenzprodukten abzuheben und
schlechtere Haltungsformen wurden dann
eher nicht gekennzeichnet ein
staatliches eine staatliche
Kennzeichnung hingegen soll die
endverbraucherinnen neutral informieren
sie wird kontrolliert und ist
verpflichtend das Gesetz ist damit ein
Schritt in die richtige Richtung
doch nun zu den Lücken
zuerst wäre aus meiner Sicht eine
Anpassung der Tierschutzgesetzgebung und
der nutztierhalt der Verordnung nötig
und wichtig als erster Schritt hierdurch
wäre eine Anhebung des gesetzlichen
Mindeststandards für alle Tierarten
möglich dies ist längst über einfällig
der Minister sagte eben wir müssen
endlich loslegen Kolleginnen Mittag
sagte 9 Gesetze sind in der Pipeline die
sind angekündigt und ich sag tun sie es
wir werden hier konstruktiv mitarbeiten
kritisches zweitens aus meiner Sicht
dass die vorgeschlagenen Regelungen
nicht geeignet sind den gesamten
Lebenszyklus aller Tierarten abzubilden
und dies bedeutet würde bedeuten die
Bewertung von der Erzeugung bis hin zu
Schlachtung auf alle tierischen Produkte
sowohl für Einheimische als auch für
Importprodukte und dies gemeinsam in
Europa das wäre Komplettlösung
ein dieses Siegel bildet nur den
aktuellen Zustand ab aber unser Ziel
muss es sein den Standard in der
Tierhaltung konsequent
weiterzuentwickeln ihn über alle
Tierarten und Wirtschaftsformen hinweg
deutlich anzuheben und zwar gemeinsam
mit den Tierhaltern das kann ich hier
nur wiederholen die bäuerlichen
Landwirtschaftsbetriebe kritisieren dass
die Empfehlung der borcherkommission
viel weitreichende und zukunftsweisender
waren als dieser Gesetzesentwurf es
empfehle an einer Synchronisierung
zwischen tierhaltungskennzeichen
Nutztierhaltung Verordnung Finanzierung
Baurecht und emissionsschutzrecht ein
weiterer Kritikpunkt
diese zusätzliche Kennzeichnung wird die
Verbraucherinnen und Verbraucher
befürchte ich verwirren weil die
bestehenden Kennzeichnungen nicht
kompatibel sind mit dem angestrebten
Kritikpunkt Nummer 5 die
VerbraucherInnen werden getäuscht über
diese Kennzeichnung sie könnten es als
tivolebel verstehen eine Aussage dass
die Tiere besonders das ist den Tieren
besonders gut gehen würde aber das ist
nicht der Fall bei dem gesetzlichen
Mindeststandards Stall ebenso wie in den
unteren Stufen des Lebens Stahl Plus ist
eine ausreichendes Mindestmaß an
Tierschutz und Tierwohl einfach eben
nicht gegeben konventionelle Tierhaltung
die in Tierwohl investiert haben welches
über die
EU-Verordnung hinausgeht landen nachdem
bisherigen Entwürfen in einer
niedrigeren Stufe als Bio-Betriebe die
nur ein absolutes Minimum erfüllen und
das darf aus meiner Sicht nicht sein
und bisher reden wir hier ausschließlich
vom Schweinefleisch es fehlen die
konkreten Termine für die Erweiterung
der Kennzeichnungspflicht auf
verarbeitete Produkte und weitere
Tierarten und auch die
Bundestierärztekammer kritisiert wie wir
dass der Entwurf weiter hinter den
Wartungen zurückbleibt selbst die
freiwillige Kennzeichnung der Handel
zuketten umfasst nämlich neben dem
Schwein auch rindgeflüge sowie Kaninchen
warum meine Damen und Herren schaffen
sie es nicht in ihrem Gesetz diese auch
mit aufzunehmen
und auch noch einen Punkt möchte ich
eingehen dieses Gesetz geht zu Lasten
Dritter der große Brocken der Kosten und
der Arbeit liegt nämlich bei den Ländern
von den 1,4 Millionen Euro
erfüllungsaufwand haben die Länder 1,34
Millionen zu tragen und auch die
praktische Umsetzung ist durch die
zuständigen Behörden der Länder zu
leisten und das sind häufig die
veterinärämte
Ämter deren B und Überlastung haben wir
hier in der vergangenen Woche debattiert
und uns ganz klar vor Augen geführt
verehrte Kollegen aus der Ampel sie
wollen mit diesem Gesetz dem Verbraucher
Orientierung geben und ich sage Ihnen
gerade in diesen Zeiten man muss sich
eine Wahl zwischen Stall und Bio erstmal
leisten können und solange dies nicht
der Fall ist hilft uns die Kennzeichnung
nicht weiter
vielen Dank
ihnen Latendorf war das sie ist Opfer im
Ausschuss aber auch Sprecherin für
Landwirtschaft ländlich Räume und
Tierschutz Ergebnis der namentlichen
Schlussabstimmung über den Gesetzentwurf
zur Einführung einer strompreisbremse
mitteilen abgegebene Stimmkarten 661
mit ja haben gestimmt
273 mit Nein haben gestimmt
Enthaltungen
101 der Gesetzentwurf ist damit
angenommen und damit kommt die
Strompreise Bremse wie zu erwarten war
gab es die Zustimmung dafür
ist 90 die Grünen sie hat das Wort
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen es geht um die Zukunft der
Tierhaltung wir haben jetzt viel an
Kritik gehört aber
trotz alledem bin ich der festen
Überzeugung dass hier vorgelegt wurde
wirklich ein ein und der Grundstein für
den Umbau der Tierhaltung in Deutschland
und auch in der Europäischen Union meine
Damen und Herren und wenn das abgegrenzt
wird hier an manchen Stellen zu anderen
schon existierenden Siegeln oder so es
reicht eben nicht ein freiwilliges
Siegel zu haben und zu beten dass
möglichst viele mitmachen meine Damen
und Herren deshalb verstehe ich gar
nicht warum sie das immer hochheben an
den Kriterien festgemacht die Frage ist
nicht nur welche Kriterien da sind
sondern wie viel in der Realität am Ende
auch umgebaut wird welche Perspektiven
die Bauern haben das ist der
entscheidende Punkt ja gut und Lesen
erleichtert ja auch als allererstes will
ich mal sagen
der ganze Bereich der Tierhaltung steht
sowieso vor einer Umwälzung und wir
müssen eines leisten müssen eines
leisten dass wir das ganze jetzt
irgendwie auch strukturieren es wird zum
einen immer mehr gibt es immer mehr
Menschen die pflanzliche Alternativen
Essen das ist auch eine Konkurrenz aber
auch eine Chance für den Ackerbau der
Fleischkonsum in Deutschland einige
klatschen genau der Fleischkonsum in
Deutschland singt deutlich wir
produzieren vieles für den Export meine
Damen und Herren die produzieren aber
auch selbst mittlerweile wir wissen über
Problemlagen an der Stelle 40% aller
geschlachteten Schweine weist
organbefunde also Krankheiten aus meine
Damen und Herren bei der Schlachtung und
die Realität in der Fleischindustrie
auch bei uns ist im wahrsten Sinne des
Wortes auch geschönt und dann sagen die
Bauern wir wissen ja dass es einen
Rückgang der Betriebe gibt vorne an bei
den Schweinehaltern sie sagen wir wollen
endlich verlässliche Linien haben wohin
wir uns ausrichten sollen wir wollen
eine Perspektive und ich sage Ihnen
dieser Gesetz hier den Cem Özdemir
vorgelegt hat ist der Grundstein dafür
etwas Neues zu bauen und zwar
systematisch wir werden am Ende werden
in Deutschland sowieso weniger Tiere
gehalten es wird wahrscheinlich auch
weniger Exportorientierung geben aber
was ist auch geben muss ist dass es mehr
Akzeptanz geben kann für Tierhaltung in
Deutschland deshalb allein muss sie sich
verändern das Tierhaltung in Deutschland
vereinbar im Einklang ist mit dem
Vorschriften des Grundgesetzes des
Tierschutzes mit Klima mit Artenvielfalt
und das alles wollen wir bauen und ich
finde nach 16 Jahren ist es unsere
verdammte Pflicht immer dies zu
diskutieren jetzt tatsächlich ein System
aufzulegen das übrigens nicht nur Umbar
macht sondern auch den Bäuerinnen und
Bauern den tierhalterinnen die jetzt
Tiere schon anders halten als im
gesetzlichen Mindeststandards eine faire
Präsentationsmöglichkeit an den Markt zu
geben meine Damen und Herren dass sie
ja sehr gut ich sehe hier sind die Fans
von ITW
ITW ich weiß dass sie bei ITW schon
längste Gutachten haben und in Brüssel
das ganze versuchen zu torpedieren an
der Stelle so was lieben wir ja wenn man
sozusagen anderen Orts die
Bundesregierung torpedieren möchte tun
Sie das ruhig aber belegen Sie uns mal
belegen Sie uns mal wo
ITW zu einem grundsätzlichen Umbau
geführt haben meine Damen und Herren auf
die Zahlen warte ich noch nein nicht
natürlich ja ich gehe in den Laden ich
weiß nicht wo sie hingehen und dann
finden Sie obere haltungsstufen fast
überhaupt nicht sie können mir viel
erzählen und ich sage Ihnen wie wir den
Umbau machen es wird so sein meine Damen
und Herren das hier das ist ja der
Grundstein wir werden in den nächsten
Monaten weitermachen mit der Ausweitung
auf verarbeitete Produkte mit der
Ausweitung nicht nur auf den Handel
sondern auf die Gastronomie sie werden
es im Restaurant bei der außer Haus
verpflegen sehen es werden weitere Arten
dazu kommen weil sie kennen sich ein
Unrecht sehr gut aus sie erstmal
eingesetztentwurf notifizieren müssen in
Brüssel dann kommen die
Rechtsverordnungen für den gesamten
Lebenszyklus für andere Tierarten dann
kommt da werden sie es bestimmt
unterstützen die Novellierung des
Tierschutzgesetzes da werden wir mal all
die Ausnahmen die sie in 16 Jahren nicht
gestrichen haben endlich wegkriegen wir
werden eine Herkunftskennzeichnung
machen und sie werden beim Anfang
sowieso schon erkennen wo gekennzeichnet
ist es garantiert deutsches Fleisch drin
wir werden eine haben
wir zum Schluss eine Ernährungsstrategie
auflegen die auch auf der Nachfrage
Seite dafür sorgt dass etwas was
transparent ist für die Hersteller und
für die Kundinnen und Kunden meine Damen
und Herren gekauft
frau Präsidentin ich nehme den mal
rauszuheit Stegemann sie wir haben hier
viel erzählt sie haben viel erzählt von
einem Vorspiel dass sie angeblich die
Vorarbeit geleistet hätten an der stelle
ich sage Ihnen mal 16 Jahre Vorspiel
sind nicht genug es
muss äußersten kommen
[Applaus]
das war ein langer letzter Satz von
Renate Künast die wahrscheinlich hier
einen kleinen geburtstagsbonus hatte
auch wenn Sie hier doch die Redezeit
deutlich überzogen hat Christina stumpf
jetzt für die Unionsfraktion
der Präsidentin sehr geehrter Minister
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
VerbraucherInnen Verbraucher sondern auf
einen Blick erkennen wie ein Tier in
landwirtschaftlichen Betrieben in
Deutschland gehalten werden kann
zukünftig das ist das was dies sehr
geehrter Minister mit dem
tierhaltungskennzeichnungsgesetz
erreichen wollen und das begrüßen wir
als Union wie so oft in ihrer Regierung
ist das Gesetz aber handwerklich
schlecht gemacht denn mit dem
vorliegenden Entwurf erreichen Sie genau
das Gegenteil sie kennzeichnen mit den
vorgelegten fünf haltungsstufen
ausschließlich die Schweinemast wenn Sie
eine Familie zu Weihnachten in guten
Schweinebraten gönnen will weiß sie zwar
zukünftig beim Kauf unter welchen
Bedingungen das Schwein gemästet wurde
sie weiß aber nicht unter welchen
Umständen das Zwerge geboren und wo es
aufgezogen wurde
wurde es vielleicht dem Ausland
betäubungslos kastriert und anschließend
importiert hat das Schwein nach der Mast
bei Transport und Schlachtung womöglich
unnötig gelitten fragen über Fragen die
weiter offen bleiben so viel zur
Transparenz und Ehrlichkeit der Grünen
und die Liste lässt sich noch weiter
fortsetzen die Kennzeichen ist nur für
frisches Schweinefleisch vorgesehen bei
der von Ihnen geplanten Regelungen
würden Sie also maximal 25% des
Schweinefleisches kennzeichnen es fehlen
verarbeitete waren es fehlen die
Vertriebswege der Gastronomie und der
außer hausverpflegung es fehlen die
anderen Tierarten ihr Stückwerk Herr
Minister verspielt das Vertrauen unserer
Verbraucher
auch die von Ihnen vorgesehenen eigenen
Stufen für Bio innerhalb der Logik einer
tierhaltungskennzeichnung schafft für
Wirkung gerade die Einordnung der
ökologischer Zeugen tierischen
Lebensmittel in die oberste Stufe
suggeriert dass es sich dabei um die
beste haltungsstufe handelt für die
Stufe Bio gelten aber anders als wir die
anderen vier haltungsstufen nicht die
Vorgaben des
tierhaltungskennzeichensgesetzes sondern
die der EU öko-
bereits jetzt gehen einige
privatwirtschaftliche
Kennzeichnungssysteme vom Umfang her
über das von ihnen geplant ist Siegel
deutlich hinaus so sind dort unter
anderem auch andere Tierarten und die
Finanzierung schon im Begriffen ein
gutes Beispiel ist hier die bereits
erwähnte Initiative Tierwohl schauen wir
auf den Handel und die bereits
etablierte Kennzeichnungen mit den
heilungsstufen 1 bis 4 diese ist bei den
Verbraucher bei der verbraucherschaft
schon hinreichend bekannt und akzeptiert
wenn das tierhaltungskennzeichen
Kraft tritt wie es hier vorliegt wird
die Kennzeichen dieses
freiwilligenprogramms für frische
Schweinefleisch in der aktuellen Form
überhaupt nicht mehr möglich sein
das heißt das bisher gefrierstufige
System wird nicht weiter verwerten
weiter verwendet werden kann die
Leistung der privatwirtschaftlichen
Programme werden in den Folge wegbrechen
das Tierwohl Niveau in Deutschland wird
dramatisch sinken und ein Großteil der
Tierhaltung wird ins Ausland verlagert
das
kann es vorhaben sein
und wenn sie
nein sicherlich nicht fragt sie
verantwortlich aber wenn Sie es mit mehr
verbrauchertransparent wirklich ehrlich
meinen und dann beziehen sie auch
ausländische Produkte zur gleichen
Bedingungen in die verbindliche
haltungskennzeichnung ein denn sonst ist
das geradezu eine Einladung zu
Verbraucher Täuschung das Gesetz enthält
nämlich keine Regelungen die unsere
Behörden ermächtig die Einhaltung der
jeweiligen
Haltungsanforderungen freiwilligen
teilnehmende ausländische Betriebe
unmittelbar zu überprüfen geschweige
denn diese vor Ort kontrollieren zu
können liebe Damen und Herren und das
wird für mich gleich zum nächsten Aspekt
die tierhaltungskennzeichnung muss mit
einer
herkunftszeitung einhergehen denn nur
dann weiß ich als Konsumenten
verlässlich ob ich die beste und
lückenlos kontrollierte Qualität aus
Deutschland auf den Teller bekommen
die Verbraucherinnen und Verbraucher
wollen fünfmal Deutschland von der
Geburt bis zur Verarbeitung sie wollen
eine umfassende Haltung sind tierpensum
herkunftskennzahlen überall in der
Gastronomie und in der außer Haus
Verpflegung sehr geehrter Herr Minister
inzwischen den Ankündigungen ihrer
Vorhaben und deren Umsetzung vergeht
sehr sehr viel Zeit zu viel Zeit sei der
Vorstellung ihre Eckpunkte zur
tierhaltungskennzeichnungsgesetz sind
sagen und schreibe sechs Monate
vergangen sechs Monate in denen sie auf
die zahlreiche Kritik der Beteiligten
Player hätten eingehen können ich
verstehe sie wollen in die Veränderung
einsteigen aber dass ihr das Gesetz der
Gesetzesentwurf in der Verbandsanhörung
von den Landwirten über die
Schlachtunternehmen bis hin zu den
Tierschutzorganisation durch die Bank
verrissen wurde und nun mehr auch im
Agrarausschuss des Bundesrates abgelehnt
worden ist können sie doch nicht einfach
ignorieren
und nur mit allen Beteiligten ist die
Veränderung möglich und nicht gegen sie
lassen Sie unsere Landwirte nicht weiter
in der Ungewissheit und mit
Zukunftssorgen auf debarte Bank sitzen
wir alle wollen den Umbau der
Tierhaltung dazu braucht es aber nicht
nur ein vollständiges
tierhaltungskennzeichensgesetz dass alle
Wertschöpfungsstufen alle Tierarten und
alle Vertriebskanälen umfasst sondern
zeitgleich auch ein Änderung des Bau-
und emissionsschutzrechtes und
insbesondere eine langfristige planbare
und auskömmliche Finanzierung nur mit
einem guten Gesamtkonzept wird der Weg
zu mehr Tierwohl gelingen vielen Dank
Christina Stumpe war das und weil hier
die Tierwohl Initiative schon häufiger
genannt wird erinnere ich nur einmal an
den Sommer da hat diese Initiative
durchaus auch Schlagzeilen gemacht weil
einige Schlachtbetriebe denn betrieben
die mit diesem Tierwohl
in Verbindung stehen gekündigt haben
weil anscheinend ist nicht genügend
Nachfrage für Tierwohl Fleisch gibt
unter anderem auch der Schlachtbetrieb
Turniers Präsidentin werte Kolleginnen
und Kollegen sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren sehr geehrter Herr Minister die
Landwirtschaft steht vor einem Neuanfang
eine neue Ära beginnt mit diesem
Gesetzentwurf und ähm ja ihre Richtung
gerichtet wir machen es jetzt einfach
und wir wollen eigentlich mit dem reden
wir die Umbau der Nutztierhaltung in
Deutschland soll damit an den auf den
Weg gebracht werden der Gesetzesentwurf
schafft eine staatliche
nutztierhaltungskennzeichnung für
Frischfleisch gekennzeichnet werden fünf
verschiedene Haltungsformen für
Frischfleisch beginnt mit
Schweinefleisch die Stallhaltung
Stallhaltung plus Haltung im
frischluftstall die auslufthaltung ist
genauso wie die Freilandhaltung und die
Biohaltung mit der staatlichen
haltungskennzeichnung wollen wir den
beim Einkauf für VerbraucherInnen
transparente und gezielte
Kaufentscheidungen ermöglichen und
zugleich auch den Tierschutz stärken
ja wenn wir ein Überleben der
Tierhaltung in Deutschland langfristig
sichern wollen brauchen wir eben auch
die gesellschaftliche Akzeptanz die
können wir nur erreichen wenn die
Nutztierhaltung für die Tiere genug
platzlicht Auslauf Beschäftigung und
Hygiene im stallvorhält die Bilder aus
dem Betrieben wo Tiere vernachlässigt
oder misshandelt werden die in den
letzten Wochen und Monaten immer wieder
durch die Medien gingen zeigen ja ganz
deutlich dass wir jetzt endlich auch mal
handeln müssen wir brauchen mehr
effizientere Kontrollen in den Betrieben
und wir müssen auch Straftaten zu lassen
von Tieren konkret und konsequent auch
verfolgen
von 2023 bis 2026 haben wir für den
Umbau der Tierhaltung insgesamt eine
Milliarde Euro vorgesehen davon werden
2023 über ein neues Bundesprogramm 150
Millionen für die Stall Umbauten für den
Anfang und für die tiergerechte um für
den tiergerechten Umbau zur Verfügung
gestellt der Nutztierhaltung geben wir
eben dann genau diese Planungssicherheit
bei den Kosten für den Umbau und auch
für die laufenden Mehrkosten in den
Stellen die hoffentlich für mehr
Tierwohl sorgen werden zur Finanzierung
werden derzeit ja unterschiedliche
Modelle diskutiert und ich möchte da
auch heute noch mal bei Ihnen hier
werben für das bürokratiearme Modell der
Steuererhöhung denn regelmäßige
Steuereinnahmen lassen uns den Arm Umbau
in den Landwirtschaft eben langfristig
auch sicher finanzieren und in vielen
Gesprächen die ich mit LandwirtInnen
geführt habe ist das auch meines
Erachtens eine berechtigte Forderung
bevor wir neue Bürokratiemonster
errichten
parallel können wir da eben auch und das
ist ja auch oft schon Thema gewesen oft
Steuern für Obst und Gemüse auch mal
überlegen runterzusetzen und diese
wichtige Maßnahme dann eben auch
gesundheitspolitisch zu flankieren als
Tierschutzbeauftragte der
spd-bundesfraktion Bundestagsfraktion
ist mir aber besonders wichtig dass die
Kennzeichnung natürlich am Ende auch das
hält was sie verspricht und deshalb ist
natürlich der Punkt der und die Kritik
die angebracht wurde dass wir noch mal
überlegen müssen nicht nur die die
masthase staatlich zu kennzeichnen
sondern eben in dem Zusammenhang jetzt
auch den kompletten Lebenszyklus in den
Blick zu nehmen und vom Gesetzentwurf
erfassen zu lassen die Geburt Aufzucht
und Ferkel der Ferkel über die
maßtransport und Schlachtung müssen wir
einbeziehen wir müssen eben auch den
saunhaltern und der Ferkelzucht hier in
Deutschland eine Perspektive geben dass
sie auch von den Förderprogramm
profitieren und eben auch für die Tiere
mehr Tierschutz ermöglichen
bei der Kennzeichnung selber besteht für
meinen Geschmack auch ein wenig
Handlungsbedarf Auslauf und
Freilandhaltung sollten für mich nicht
auf einer Ebene nebeneinander stehen die
Änderungen dazu in der
nutztierhaltungsverordnung müssen wir
unbedingt konkretisieren wir müssen
definieren wie ein Auslauf beschaffen
sein soll damit wir am Ende überhaupt
feststellen können ob Auslauf und
Freilandhaltung vergleichbar sind und
auch nebeneinander stehen können denn
wer Tiere aktuelle in einem
geschlossenen Stall hält und lediglich
eine Wand entfernt und davor eine kleine
Betonplatte zementiert und ein
sogenannten Auslauf anbietet der würde
dann von Stallhaltung mit dieser kleinen
Maßnahme nach oben in die
Freilandhaltung und Auslauf gelangen und
das suggeriert dann am Ende doch
vielleicht äh was was wir den
Verbrauchern eben nicht suggerieren
sollten einen sogenanntes Tierwohl was
auf dieser Ebene dann eigentlich gar
nicht gegeben ist die Freilandhaltung
ist eben nach Tiere Tierwohl
Gesichtspunkten eine premiumhaltung und
deshalb muss diese meines Erachtens für
sich stehen oder wir müssen auch
überlegen ob diese nicht neben der
Biohaltung aufstehen sollte
mehr Tierwohl da ist vielleicht noch ein
Punkt den ich gerne ansprechen möchte
zwingend für mich dass wir auch auf
allen in allen zu allen
haltungshaltungskennzeichnungen
überlegen Liegebereiche mit Stroh
einzustreuen Tiere die dauerhaft auf
Betonplatten oder auf Spalten liegen das
muss endlich auch mal der Vergangenheit
angehören und ja weil Tiere eben auch
ein Recht haben auch mal weich liegen zu
dürfen liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
außerdem ist Stroh aber mit vielen
LandwirtInnen im Gespräch hat sich
herausgestellt dass auch Stroh eben
Beschäftigungsmaterial ist und das
Tierwohl das natürliche Verhalten von
Schweinen in den Stellen fördert und
damit auch ganz oft sich dieses immer
wieder auftretende Ringelschwanz beißen
eben auch maßgebliche reduziert wenn wir
diese Maßnahme eben für alle
haltungsstufen auch ergreifen würden
staatliches Geld für den Umbau gibt es
eben nur einmal liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen und deshalb werden wir in den
nächsten Wochen darüber sprechen müssen
dass wir die Anforderungen doch dann
auch so hochschrauben wie möglich damit
wir am Ende auch
da ankommen wir ankommen wollen dass wir
möglichst viel Tierwohl auch erreichen
für VerbraucherInnen ist wichtig die
Erweiterung der Kennzeichnung eben auf
die außer hausverpflegung Gastronomie
und verarbeitete Produkte und das werden
wir in den kommenden Gesprächen auch
noch mal nachjustieren es liegt eben es
ist eben so dass kein Parlament kein
Gesetz aus dem Parlament rausgeht so wie
es reingekommen ist auch da haben wir
das wissen wir alle und ähm in diesem
Sinne wünsche ich mir dass dieses Gesetz
eben entscheidend dazu beiträgt
Tierschutz Transparenz für
VerbraucherInnen und Planungssicherheit
am Ende auch für unsere Landwirtschaft
zu gewährleisten und wir werden das
Realität werden lassen das Fundament ist
durch den Gesetzesentwurf des BML gelegt
worden und ich freue mich auf die
Beratung vielen Dank
immer wieder wird hier in der Debatte
betont dass dieser Gesetzentwurf ja noch
diskutiert wird im Ausschuss und das ist
dort ja noch einige Änderungsvorschläge
gibt die dürfte auch Peter Felser haben
für die afd-fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin Herr
Minister liebe Kollegen liebe Gäste
Liebe Landwirte dass die von Ihnen
geplante tierhaltungskennzeichnung
grundre produktiv für alle Beteiligten
wäre das hat mein Kollege brotger schon
ausgeführt und zu Recht bekommen sie
dafür von allen Seiten innerhalb der
Branche Kritik ich zitiere Erlaubnis
frau Präsidentin den Verband der
Fleischwirtschaft das Gesetz wird nichts
zum Umbau der Tierhaltung beitragen
sondern zum Abbau der
Versorgungssicherheit aus deutscher
Fleischerzeugung und vermutlich auch zum
Abbau der bereits erreichten
tierhaltungsfortschritte Zitat Ende und
das muss doch allen hier Anwesenden zu
denken geben das können wir doch gerade
in der aktuellen Krise nicht zulassen
liebe Kollegen
was hingegen eine starke Unterstützung
für die Branche und alle Beteiligten
wäre und auch schon längst überfällig
ist das ist die verbindliche
Herkunftskennzeichnung von Lebensmitteln
insgesamt wir haben das schon wiederholt
gefordert und erneuern diese Forderung
heute mit unserem Antrag die Realität
sieht doch so aus dass sich die deutsche
Landwirtschaft in einem harten
Verdrängungswettbewerb befindet gegen
die dumping Lebensmitteln aus dem
Ausland haben die heimischen Landwirte
effektiv kaum Chancen Umwelt und
Tierschutz spielen bei der Erzeugung im
Ausland kaum eine Rolle
das ist doch auch jedem hier in Wahrheit
bewusst eine transparente Kennzeichnung
der Herkunft könnte das jedoch
entscheidend verändern es kann doch
nicht sein liebe Kollegen das ist
Lebensmittel gibt die Zutaten aus Polen
aus China aus Brasilien enthalten aber
der Verbraucher sieht das gar nicht im
Lebensmittelmarkt was ist denn das für
eine Kennzeichnung wenn draufsteht Honig
aus EU und nicht EU-Ländern hallo aus
nicht die EU-Ländern also von der ganzen
Welt von ganzen Planeten das ist doch
keine Verbraucherinformation das ist
eine Veräppelung der Verbraucher sonst
gar nichts
bei mir im Allgäu bei mir im Allgäu wird
Allgäuer Milch vermarktet die zum Teil
gar nicht aus dem Allgäu kommt wo Allgäu
Milch draufsteht muss zukünftig auch
allgäuerlich drin sein liebe Kollegen
Punkt alles andere wäre Verbraucher
Täuschung
für diese Herkunftskennzeichnung werden
heimisch erzeugt der Produkte auf einen
Schlag für jeden sichtbar Verarbeitung
verbraucher können sich also bewusst für
heimische Produkte und damit für sehr
hohe Tierschutz und Umweltstandards
entscheiden von allen relevanten
Umfragen wissen wir dass das draußen bei
den Verbraucher und auch explizit
erwünscht ist dass diese wichtige
Entscheidung immer wieder auf die lange
Bank geschoben wird ist unverantwortlich
Österreich Frankreich und Schweden sind
hier bereits erfolgreich
vorangeschritten es gibt also keine
sachlichen
und fachlichen Grund warum wir das nicht
auch sofort einführen könnten hier in
Deutschland mit unserem Antrag geben wir
Ihnen heute die Gelegenheit genau diese
Herkunftskennzeichnung endlich auch bei
uns in Deutschland einzuführen vielen
Dank und gesegnete Weihnachten
FDP-Fraktion hat das Wort dr Gero Hocker
ist der stellvertretende Vorsitzende des
Ausschusses für Ernährung und
Landwirtschaft
frau Präsidentin vorweg ein Wort in
eigener Sache der Umstand dass einige
Kolleginnen und Kollegen auch ich heute
etwas verschwitzt vor ihnen stehen die
ich daran dass zeitgleich ein benefizit
sein Tischtennis Benefizturnier
stattfindet hier im Hause
fraktionsübergreifen zugunsten vom
Parkinson Erkrankten und ich möchte auch
wenn er gerade nicht dabei sein kann
Albert Stegemann ganz herzlich danken
dass er als Schirmherr in dieser dieser
wichtigen Funktion deswegen ist heute
nicht da also vielen Dank an alle die
teilgenommen haben
meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren
viele Menschen behaupten sie würden
gerne mehr Steuern zahlen als das von
ihnen gesetzgeberisch erwartet ist dass
Konto für freiwillige Zuwendung des
Bundes freut sich in den letzten
elfeinhalb Monaten des Jahres 2022 über
ganze 51
000 € und das bei ungefähr 46 Millionen
steuerpflichtig Lohn und
einkommensteuerpflichtigen Menschen in
Deutschland und auch bei der Frage was
Menschen für Lebensmittel ausgeben
behaupten ganz viele dass sie gerne
bereit wären ein höheren Preis für
Lebensmittel zu bezahlen wir wissen aber
seit vielen Jahren das ungefähr nur
jeder zehnte Menschen tatsächlich seinen
Ankündigungen auch Taten folgen lassen
lässt an der Supermarktkasse und das ist
eine fatale Entwicklung meine Damen und
Herren denn so werden gerade diejenigen
aus dem Markt heraus getrennt die schon
jetzt nach höchsten Standards häufig in
den allermeisten Fällen in Deutschland
Lebensmittel erzeugen und diejenigen
werden honoriert die das im Ausland tun
so häufig sehr viel niedrigeren
Standards und deswegen sehr verehrte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ist der Gesetz
lieber hier gefordert endlich mehr
Transparenz walten zu lassen
es wird argumentiert dass die Mangel
Transparenz mangelnde Deklaration der
Grund dafür ist ich will es nur mal ganz
am Rande sagen auch jetzt gibt es ja
durchaus Orientierung dafür beim Kauf
von Lebensmitteln darauf zu achten dass
es ein möglichst kleinen CO2-Fußabdruck
gibt das ist Tieren gut gegangen ist das
hohe Standards eingehalten wurden und da
kann ich nur an alle Verbraucher
appellieren regional und saisonal
einzukaufen damit es übrigens jetzt
schon vor Einführung des sinnvoll die
hat uns Kennzeichnung des Gesetzes
tatsächlich ein großer Dienst erwiesen
für Nachhaltigkeit und für Biodiversität
meine Damen und Herren aber
diese Koalition geht trotzdem weiter
erstmals in der Geschichte dieses Landes
soll es möglich sein auf den ersten
Blick zu erkennen wie und wo ein Tier
und nach welchen Standards es gehalten
wurde und das meine sehr verehrten Damen
und Herren ist weit mehr als in den
letzten Jahren und Jahrzehnten bei einer
Vielzahl von vergeigten versuchen das zu
erreichen von Seiten der Union gekommen
ist werte Kolleginnen und Kollegen
aber uns ist klar
ein Kennzeichen alleine wird nicht
ausreichend meine Damen und Herren
sondern wir müssen auch die
Voraussetzungen schaffen dafür dass
Umbau auch tatsächlich erfolgen kommen
wir müssen endlich ans Baugesetz ran
damit die Kommunen vor Ort damit die
Landkreise vor Ort tatsächlich auch
endlich Genehmigungen erteilen damit
Landwirte in neue oder ein umgebaute
Stallungen überhaupt investieren können
und das überhaupt auch umgesetzt werden
kann fertig Kollege und Kollegen wir
werden sehr genau in den nächsten Wochen
und Monaten darauf achten dass nicht
quasi durch die Hintertür mit der
Novelle des Baugesetzbuches dafür
gesorgt wird dass es insgesamt weniger
Tiere geben muss der meine Damen und
Herren wenn der Fleischkonsum sich nicht
ändert würde das würde bedeuten dass
dann eben mehr tierische Produkte aus
dem Ausland nach Deutschland importiert
werden würden und dann würde man
tatsächlich dem Ziel von der Tierwohl
und mehr Transparenz tatsächlich ein
Bären dienstlicherweise deswegen werden
wir bei den Verhandlungen während der
nächsten Wochen Monate genau darauf
achten dass das nicht passiert fertig
Kollege
und ich will einen zweiten Punkt machen
der uns während der Verhandlungen sehr
wichtig ist meine Damen und Herren ob
ein Tier Bio ernährt wurde und Biofutter
bekommen hat sagt nichts aber auch
wirklich gar nichts aus darüber wie gut
es dem Tier zu Lebzeiten gegangen ist
wie viel Platz es gab deswegen muss man
auch hier sehr wohl noch sehr intensive
Diskussionen führen und das sehr wohl
hinterfragen ob diese Systematik
tatsächlich sinnlos ist als eine
haltungs kennzeichnet tatsächlich das
Bio-Label zu verwenden und meine Damen
und Herren das ist mir besonders
wichtige meiner Fraktion insgesamt wir
werden auch darauf achten dass
bestehende Strukturen die bereits seit
sehr vielen Jahren eine erheblichen
Beitrag dafür leisten
privatwirtschaftlich organisiert häufig
genug dass tatsächlich sinnvoll und
effektiv kontrolliert wird das Betriebe
sich an bestimmte Standards und Vorgaben
halten das solche Strukturen nicht
zerschlagen werden sondern all das was
der Gesetzgeber jetzt auf den Weg bringt
auch diese Ideen und diese erwiesen
guten Konzepte aufbaut vielen Dank fürs
zuhören
Gero Hocker war das für die
FDP-Fraktion und damit kommen wir zum
vorletzten Redner in dieser Debatte das
ist Max Straubinger für die
Unionsfraktion
Gesetze Präsidentin wird die Kolleginnen
und Kollegen wir unterhalten uns sehr
über den Gesetzentwurf der
Bundesregierung über die Tierwohl
Kennzeichnung und außer Frage ist wir
stehen natürlich auch dafür dass das
Tierwohl im Mittelpunkt steht und das
ist auch gekennzeichnet und dargestellt
wird aber das muss auch richtig erfolgen
und nicht so lückenhaft und so schlecht
letztendlich wie dieses Gesetz gemacht
ist meine Vorrednerin die geschätzten
haben der bereits darauf hingewiesen
selbst aus der Koalition heraus jetzt
hat der Kollege Hocker ebenfalls auf die
Defizite sozusagen dieses Gesetzes
hingewiesen und es zeigt da auch sehr
deutlich die Abstimmung im Bundesrat die
Frau Kollegin hat sie auch schon mit
dargelegt
sie Mehrzahl der Landwirtschaft die
Mehrzahl der Landwirtschaftsminister im
Bundesrat haben es abgelehnt auch die
Grünen
Landwirtschaftsminister im
Agrarausschuss wurde es abgelehnt immer
geradeausschuss wurde es abgelehnt und
im Plenum gab es 58 Einwände dann
nachher also die zu erfüllen sind
ein zum Beispiel es Europa weiter zur
Kennzeichnungen hier herbeizuführen hier
ist diese Bundesregierung nicht schafft
und nicht kann sie sind ja früher immer
sie haben ja früher sie haben ja früher
uns auch immer gefordert wir sollen es
europaweit also hier schaffen und wir
haben Ihnen immer entgegengehalten dass
europaweit einfach nicht geht denn die
europäischen anderen sind nicht bereit
dazu hier dementsprechend also auch
mitzuziehen und das ist letztendlich
Aufgabe und sie werden auch wieder nicht
schaffen Frau Künast aber ich freue mich
auf Ihre Zwischenfrage sehr gut
Renate aus dem grünen Fraktion also
ich wollte mal sagen ich weiß nicht wie
sie jetzt akut über den Button auf
europäischer Ebene informiert sind weil
sie haben ja jetzt schon mit ihrer Rede
nachdem mehrere koalitionsfraktions
Menschen auch der Minister gesagt hat
dass dieses das erste Gesetz in einem
ganzen Paket ist also all die Dinge die
sie als Mangel begreifen beschreiben in
diesem Park in diesem Gesetz ist ja
aufgeführt worden dass sie alle kommen
dass weitere Tierarten dass die
Gastronomie kommt Tierschutzgesetz und
so weiter und eine
Herkunftskennzeichnung und jetzt frage
ich mich haben sie sich akut eigentlich
mal informiert über das was auf
europäischer Ebene läuft das nämlich die
EU-Kommission durchaus mit Interesse
bisher zumindest auf diesen Entwurf
gucken wir wollen ihn ja in Europa
müssen ihn notifizieren lassen auch
anderen Mitgliedstaaten eine Chance
geben daran teilzunehmen was darin sein
soll und dass wir dann den Türöffner
haben das wirklich rasant für alle
anderen Dinge mitzumachen nehmen Sie zur
Kenntnis dass bei dieser Geschichte die
EU-Kommission mit Interesse drauf guckt
dass ein Mitgliedschaft vorangeht war
das auch ein Modell sein kann für die ab
der EU-Kommission dann selber auch ein
EU-weiten Vorschlag zu machen ob der
durchkommt oder nicht wissen wir doch
nicht oder wissen Sie heute schon wie in
ein zwei Jahren auf europäischer Ebene
im Rat abgestimmt wird wenn ja woher
haben sie das Wissen nein das weiß ich
liebe blau Künast da kann ich Ihnen
nicht helfen ich bin kein Weissager
aber mit den Ankündigungen der
Bundesregierung der wissen wir ja schon
erhebliche Erfahrung gemacht in diesem
Jahr also es wurde beim Gas z.B große
Ankündigung gemacht des
Bundeswirtschaftsministers das ist ja
dann doch Gott sei Dank ja natürlich
nicht zustande Kamera und so zieht sich
ja das hin also auf ihre Ankündigungen
da will ich mich nicht verlassen das
einzige was Sie vielleicht zustande
bringen mit ihren Ankündigungen sie
haben da auch die Ernährungsstrategie
angekündigt sie als Rednerin da wird mir
sowieso bange dabei auch dem Bäuerinnen
und Bauern draußen wird Metall bange
denn wenn sie sich kümmern zum Beispiel
über die Kantine hier dann bei uns im
Bundestag wie die dann eingerichtet
werden soll liebe Frau Künast da wirst
es wohl besser sein ich mache dann vor
dem Bundestag draußen die Würstelbude
auf weil dann werde ich dann werde ich
wohl mehr Zulauf haben ist wie sie
Herrinnen in der körnerbude also
das ist letztendlich und das ist ja und
das ist ja Frau kühnerst die Bühne noch
nicht fertig also
nach ihrem geschäftlichen Interessen
habe ich nicht gefragt also ist das für
mich die Antwort gewesen
es geht darum letztendlich sie wollen
die Tierhaltung kaputt machen in
Deutschland und das ist mit Einsatz die
eine Frau Kollegin hat gesagt dass sie
selbst hat gesagt wir machen sozusagen
einen neuen Grundstück da wo man was
neues bauen also das klingt ja also sehr
er und großartig aber ich sage es dieses
Gesetz ist dazu angetan die Tierhaltung
in Deutschland abzubauen und nicht
aufzubauen und da haben wir einen großen
Gegensatz nämlich wir als Union wir
stehen dafür dass heimische Produkte auf
den Teller kommen und nicht dann
ausländische Produkte aus dem auf den
Teller kommen der Kollege Gero Hocker
hat gerade dies auch prophezeit das dies
kommen wird er will es zwar nicht aber
dieses Gesetz ist dazu angetan dieses
Gesetz ist dazu angetan dass zukünftig
mehr ausländische Produkte und zwar vor
allen Dingen dann tierische Produkte
Fleisch aus dem Ausland kommt das unter
schlechteren Haltungsbedingungen unter
schlechteren fütterungs und
medizinischen tierarbeit
Behandlungsbedingungen erzeugt worden
ist die spanischen Schweine Bauern die
freuen sich über unsere Gesetzgebung die
sind derzeit dabei hier noch die
Schweinehaltung auszubauen und warum
weil sie wissen dass in Deutschland
letztendlich die Tierhaltung immer
weniger werden wird weil die Bäuerinnen
und Bauern hier sich das nicht leisten
können die Anforderungen die Frau
Kollegin Luzia Bode hat vorher gesagt
hat wir müssen bei der Förderung sehr
hohe Grundsätze dann ansetzen ich habe
fast den Eindruck gehabt möglicherweise
damit die billigen und wenigen
Fördermittel von 150 Millionen Euro gar
nicht so Anwendung kommen können weil
wir so hohe Anforderungen stellen die
kein Landwirt und kein Bauer mehr
erfüllen kann bzw will und das ist
letztendlich ihre das ist doch das ist
ihre Fantasie von zukünftiger
Tierhaltung und jetzt wurde er
vielfältigste angemahnt dass das
Baurecht geändert werden musste Kollege
Hocker hat es auch hier mit angemacht
ich brauch wo ist dies hier im
Zusammenhang hier wird jetzt das
tierhaltungskennzeichen die wird
insgesamtgebung gebracht aber
gleichzeitig müssten letztendlich das
Baurecht angepasst werden gleichzeitig
müsste das Immissionsschutzgesetz
definiert werden das tun sie nicht das
tun sie nicht und ich kann sie ihnen
auch sagen warum sie es nicht tun werden
weil wir über vier Jahre nein über acht
Jahre dies versucht haben und dies von
dieser Seite dies von dieser Seite
ständig verhindert worden ist und gerade
sie haben mir gerade Sie hier mehr mit
einer der der der bei Emission Schutz in
der Regel keine Zugeständnisse gemacht
hat für die Bäuerinnen und Bauern und
darum wird es in dieser Koalition auch
nicht gelingen es ist mir sehr bewusst
und von daher wissen wir mit diesem
tierhaltungskennzeichen die heute
eingebracht worden ist wird wird
letztendlich die Tierhaltung in
Deutschland Schiffbruch erleiden und vor
allen Dingen die Bäuerinnen und Bauern
werden nicht bereit sein entsprechende
Umstellungen in den Stellen vorzunehmen
und vor allen Dingen weil auch unter den
wettbewerblichen Gesichtspunkten es
nicht zu schaffen ist und deshalb wäre
es vernünftige gewesen die auf der
Initiative Tierwohl aufzubauen oder
Borchert umzusetzen wir haben wie gute
Konzepte geliefert und dann das ist auch
von ihnen gescheitert aber vor allen
Dingen die Initiative Tierwohl die hätte
nämlich ermöglicht auch bei
ausländischen Tierhalten unerzeugen
entsprechende Überprüfungen
durchzuführen die jetzt nicht
stattfinden hier werden nur die
inländischen Erzeuger die werden mit
Bürokratie belastet die werden mit
Auflagen belastet und die ausländischen
Mitbewerber für Europa die freuen sich
denn sie können jetzt ja dann noch
günstiger hier das Schweinefleisch bei
uns mit anbieten und der Kollege Hocker
hat er daraus nicht zum Schluss dass die
Kräfte des Marktes letztendlich so groß
sein werden damit das dann die
Tierhaltung in Deutschland weniger
werden wird und das ist aber leider
Gottes auch das Ziel möchte nicht zahlen
von ihnen erwarten herzlich
Straubinger war das und damit kommen wir
zum letzten Redner bevor dieser
Gesetzentwurf an die entsprechenden
Ausschüsse überwiesen werden soll und
auch darüber entschieden wird wo ein
Antrag der afd-fraktion hinüberwiesen
wird Peggy schierenbecken und für die
Sozialdemokraten
Herr Bundesminister zu mir sehr geehrte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen meine Damen und
Herren als letzte Rednerin in der
Debatte hat man ja so ein paar Aufträge
immer und jetzt muss ich ja feststellen
dass Max Straubinger 6 Minuten hatte was
Sinnvolles zu sagen hat sie nicht
genutzt
und danke Renate danke Renate für 16
Jahre Vorspiel so aber jetzt zu meiner
eigentlichen Rede
und ach nein eine eine wichtige
Information möchte ihm auch noch sagen
auch noch mal eben zur Information an
die cdu/csu 2 2 von 16 Ländern aus dem
Bundesamt dagegen gestimmt im Bundesrat
gegen diese gegen diese Kennzeichen zwei
haben dagegen gestimmt also das war
leider dann lieber auch eine falsche
Information aber jetzt zu meiner Rede
wie gut klingt ist wenn wir lesen
Karotten von hier oder Kartoffeln aus
der Region das klingt nach einem
regionalen Produkt genau das wünsche ich
mir beim Einkaufen und Umfragen auch 76%
der VerbraucherInnen Verbraucher ist
Regionalität beim Einkauf sehr wichtig
schließlich unterstützen wir mit dem
Griff zur regionalen Produkten die
heimische Landwirtschaft sorgen für
kürzere Transportwege mehr Frische und
tragen zur Nachhaltigkeit bei das gibt
einem ein gutes Gefühl tatsächlich
jedoch sind die Begriffe von hier oder
aus der Region gesetzlich nicht
geschützt das heißt
die Karotten von hier könnten auch ein
Transportweg von 500 Kilometern hinter
sich haben oder die scheinbar-regionalen
Kartoffeln stammen tatsächlich aus Polen
mit dieser Art der regionalwerbung
werden Verbraucherinnen und Verbraucher
also gezielt getäuscht das muss endlich
aufhören
im Supermarkt kämpfen wir uns durch ein
Segel und kennzeichnungsdschungel auf zu
vielen Verpackungen stehen ihre führende
Angaben zur Herkunft oder Regionalität
der Produkte für uns VerbraucherInnen
Verbraucher ist es fast unmöglich die
wahre Herkunft auf einen Blick zu
erkennen dieser kennzeichnungsdschungel
entsteht durch ein Wildwuchs an
Freiwilligen regional Labels der
Privatwirtschaft Transparenz und
Einheitlichkeit Fehlanzeige was ist
bisher geregelt auch EU mir ist die
Angabe der Herkunft bisher nur für
wenige lebensmittelverbindlich
vorgeschrieben ich nenne einige
Beispiele bei den Eiern sehen wir dass
eine Herkunftskennzeichnung funktioniert
wenn sie verpflichtend vorgeschrieben
ist sie wissen es alle der Stempel
Aufdruck auf dem Ei zeigt uns wie die
Hände gehalten wurde und wo sie das Ei
gelegt hat
eindeutige kennzeichnet werden müssen
frisches Rindfleisch und Fisch für
frisches Obst und Gemüse ist die Angabe
des Ursprungslandes ebenfalls
verpflichtend allerdings gibt es
Ausnahmen zum Beispiel bei Bananen
Oliven
Speisekartoffeln hier ist es leider nur
freiwillig die verpflichtende
Kennzeichnung fast also nur bestimmte
Produkte vor allem betrifft sie nur
unverarbeitete Produkte das heißt selbst
das Obst Gemüse oder Fleisch wenn es
verarbeitet wird fällt das Produkt nicht
mehr unter die kennzeichnungsfläche
Pflicht es gibt also reichlich Lücken
und Nachbesserungsbedarf was verbrauchen
was brauchen die Verbraucherinnen und
Verbraucher sie brauchen sie wünschen
sich mehr Transparenz sie haben das
Recht zu erfahren woher ihre
Lebensmittel kommen schließlich ist die
Grundlage für eine bewusste
Kaufentscheidung für uns als
SPD-Fraktion ist klar wir müssen eine
verpflichtende Herkunft Angabe auf alle
Lebensmittelverpackungen sicherstellen
und zwar EU-weit das heißt die jetzige
Herkunftsbezeichnung muss ausgeweitet
werden wichtig ist uns dabei das
unbedingt auch verarbeitete Produkte
erfasst werden zum Beispiel Milch Gemüse
oder Fleisch als Zutat haben
nehmen wir das Beispiel der Tomatensuppe
die Tomaten sind die primärzutate der
Zutat der Suppe also soll deren Herkunft
in Zukunft eindeutige kennzeichnet
werden zurück zur Regionalität was
meinen sie heißt aus der Region aus
ihrem Nachbardorf aus dem Landkreis oder
aus ihrem Bundesland sie merken die
Voraussetzung für eine
verbraucherfreundliche Kennzeichnung
regionaler Lebensmittel ist eine klare
Definition des Wortes Region außerdem
wollen wir das mindestens 75 % der
Zutaten eines Produktes aus dieser
definierten Region stammen müssen nur so
verdient es diese Bezeichnung eines
regionalen Lebens fassen wir zusammen
grundsätzlich muss die künftige
Kennzeichnung von Herkunft und regalität
leicht verständlich einheitlich
vergleichbar und verbindlich sein diese
Transparenz wäre das Gegenteil des
heutigen Kennzeichnung Dschungels nur so
schaffen wir den Weg damit die
VerbraucherInnen Verbraucher informiert
und Grundstück kaufen können und wir die
Verantwortung eben auch wieder
zurückgewinnen und das Vertrauen
zurückgewinnen abschließend ist mir
wichtig zu betonen die Bundesregierung
kann hier mit unserer Unterstützung
rechnen wir von der
SPD-Bundestagsfraktion setzen uns
deutlich für eine umfassende
übersichtliche einheitliche und
staatlich festgelegte Zertifizierung ein
wir hoffen also das schnellstmöglich an
entsprechende Verordnung von der
EU-Kommission auf dem Weg gebracht wird
ich freue mich dass unsere
ernährungsminister Minister jm Özdemir
bereits zu Beginn des Jahres kommen Sie
bitte zum Schluss eine Initiative
gestartet hat dabei hat er auch eine
breite Unterstützung vieler weitere
EU-Mitgliedstaaten erhalten und das ist
genau was wir brauchen bitte
Schulterschluss die Herkunft danke
hiermit schließlich die Aussprache in
der fraktionell wird die Überweisung der
Vorlagen auf den Drucksache 48 22 und 48
89 an die in der Tagesordnung
aufgeführten Ausschüsse vorgeschlagen
gibt es weitere überweisungsvorschläge
das sehe ich nicht dann verfahren wir
wie vorgeschlagen